pfizer encore sous le feu des critiques
cette fois c'est amnesty international
qui montent au créneau pour dénoncer je
cite des déclarations trompeuses au
sujet de l'engagement du laboratoire en
matière d'équité vaccinale en fait le
bng reproche à pfizer d'avoir adopté
tout en prétendant le contraire une
politique de distribution des vaccins
largement profitable aux pays riches
donc au détriment des pays pauvres à ce
jour nous avons fourni près de 2
milliards de doses du vaccin fader bio
ntech qu'ovide 19 à 152 pays dans toutes
les régions du monde près de 10% de ces
doses ont jusqu'à présent étaient
distribuées à des pays à faible revenu
près de 10% des doses distribuées à des
pays à faible revenu comme l'afghanistan
le mali ou le niger par exemple en fait
essentiellement des pays d'afrique 10 %
c'est-à-dire 15 points 4 millions de
doses si on les compare aux 2 milliards
de doses distribuées au total par pfizer
à ce jour cela fait moins de 1% des
doses fournies alors que selon la banque
mondiale les pays à faible revenu
représente plus de 8% de la population
mondiale mieux si l'on analyse les
chiffres avancés par pfizer
les pays riches eux soit 15 % de la
population mondiale aurait reçu plus de
68 % des 2 milliards de doses déjà
distribué par le labo en clair à
population égale les pays riches ont
reçu de la part de pfizer près de 50
fois plus de vaccins les pays pauvres
files heures et bio ntech ont pour
l'instant livré aux seuls états suédois
neuf fois plus de doses de vaccins qui a
tous les pays à faible revenu réunis
grâce au prix élevé auquel ils vendent
leurs vaccins ils devraient engranger
plus de 86 milliards de dollars de
recettes d'ici à la fin de 2022 alors on
ne va pas jeter la pierre khalfa heure
par exemple selon amnesty international
toujours les pays pauvres n'ont eu accès
qu'à cent mille des 52 lyon de doses
fournies par moderna au cours des 50
derniers jours soit moins de 2% du total
et aucun des fabricants de vaccins ne
sait pour le moment plier au partage de
leurs brevets de leur savoir-faire comme
par exemple demandé par l' oms le ms qui
regrette également un retard sur les
livraisons de vaccins promis par les
états du g20 dans le cadre du dispositif
kovacs 150 millions de doses sur les 1,2
milliards promise bref le résultat c'est
4,4 pour cent de l'afrique vacciner
seulement quand l'europe en est déjà à
sa troisième dos